I'm going to solve three massive
business problems that going to take you
from 10 to $100 million. And at the end,
I'm going to walk you through the
framework so that you can apply this to
your business, your work, or your
personal brand. I recently spoke at an
event and had a Q&A section, and there
were three different business owners
that presented with different problems.
One was an appointment setting business,
and they knew how to set appointments
and build outbound teams for agencies,
coaches, consultants, whatever. The
second business was a marketing agency
for HVAC business owners. The third was
actually a very big influencer with 30
to 40 million subscribers across all
platforms with the objective of making
more money. So each of them had very
differently phrased questions, but they
were all suffering from the same
constraint and it wasn't what they
thought it was. So the first business
that asked a question was an appointment
setting business and he was saying that
his problem was that he needed to get
more customers which by the way most of
the time that's not the problem. It's
usually because the customers you have
keep leaving and that's the real
problem. And when we look at businesses
to invest in at acquisition.com, we
operate off of a singular concept, which
is the theory of constraints. A business
will grow up to its constraint and then
it will grow no longer. Most
entrepreneurs continue to work on the
things that they enjoy rather than the
things that the business needs. It's
usually because they haven't actually
identified the correct constraint. For
example, if you have a three-step sales
process and you get 50% to go through
step one, 5% to go through step two, and
then 50% to go through step three, you
could improve each of them by 10%. But
which of them makes the biggest
difference in your business? Going from
five to 15 triples the business, whereas
the other ones only incrementally
improve it by 20%. He had a very low
quality of customers. The vast majority
of customers didn't make enough money.
They didn't stay long enough. They
didn't have enough skills, etc. That was
what he thought he had to solve. I said,
"Okay, of all of the companies that
you've ever worked with, which of them
made the most money off of the
appointments that you set?" Right? And
he had a very specific answer of what
type of avatar he did best with. And so
there's two directions for that
business. One is you niche down on your
service delivery and say these are the
only types of businesses I'm going to
take because they're going to be worth
more, stay longer, refer, etc. That is
probably the easiest next step for that
business. If I were going to own this
business and I transplanted my brain and
my experience into his body, that he
could own half of a 50 to$und00 million
business that he grows over the next 5
to 10 years, picking the most valuable
business that he sets appointments for.
What would the marketing spend be of a
business that's doing $50 million a year
realistically? Probably somewhere in the
neighbor of five to$10 million a year.
So he could either partner with that
business or spend a year or two learning
how that business works. So that then he
owns both sides of it. If you partner,
you can usually go faster, but you give
up some of the upside because you slice
the pie. It's up to you. Because most
business owners, the reason they don't
create valuable businesses is because
they have to keep doing the same work
over and over again and they don't get
credit for it. were basically sentenced
to this terrible Atlas-like existence of
rolling the boulder up the hill and then
rolling it back down every every month.
But if the team that he built was 50
outbound guys this month and then next
month he starts at 50 because it's all
within the same company and then does
another 50 and then another 50 6 months
later he's got 300 outbound guys that
are all still working for him, all
generating revenue that he is owning a
slice of all of it. Business number two
was the HVAC agency. This is a business
that markets for HVAC companies. They
have 50 or so clients in that niche and
they're running campaigns across 50
different local markets. If he's able to
generate leads and fill up 50 different
HVAC services pipelines because of his
marketing prowess, he probably has the
marketing skill of a $50 to $100 million
HVAC business. If you have a $5 million
marketing agency, then it's reasonable
that some of the clients that you serve
are making $50 million in revenue off
the services you're generating and
you're getting none of that. You're only
capturing the service fee. The more
steps you take towards owning the
result, the more you're basically just
doing the business for them. But at a
certain point, you are the business. And
so, it makes sense for you to own the
economics of the business. And either
you got to learn the HVAC business or
you partner with someone who already
knows it or you could buy one. And with
your marketing prowess, you juice the
hell out of it. Most people will try and
buy it, but then also try and keep this
agency thing going, but sometimes you
got to take a half step back so you can
take 20 steps forward. The fastest way
to build a $10 million business is often
not the fastest way to build a $100
million business. If you wanted to build
a building that was 10 stories tall, you
would start with a very different
foundation. Now, imagine you built a
10-story building and then said, "Okay,
I want to build a hundredstory building
using the same foundation." You wouldn't
be able to. But that's exactly what most
entrepreneurs do when they're trying to
scale and they wonder why they're stuck
is because they built it wrong to begin
with because they were in the wrong
opportunity vehicle. One of the big
things that took me too long to learn is
it's the size of the slice of the pie
that matters, not the shape of the slice
of the pie. They obsess about the shape
of the slice rather than having a slice
that's like this of a much bigger pie.
The average IPO founder when a company
IPOs owns 12.5% of the company they
founded. because the more people you
make money, the more money you
ultimately make. The third business was
the big influencer business, 30 to 40
million subscribers across all the
platforms. And they were focusing all of
their attention on how do we get more
highquality videos out? And when I asked
them, "What problem are you trying to
solve?" They said, "We want to make more
money." You're seeing your business as
this box of media and trying to make
more better videos, which if you wanted
to do brand and just continue to build
the brand before making an ask, that
would be the right problem to solve. But
they were at 97 out of 100. They're a
0.0000 0000001%
creator. So, do we really think that
their constraint of their business is
that they aren't good enough at
marketing? No, probably not. You guys
are trying to take your 97 out of 100
media company to a 99 out of 100 media
company when the objective you said was
to make more money and you have no
product that you sell. So all of your
monetization relies on sponsorships and
ad and ad revenue which is typically the
least efficient way to monetize because
anyone who pays you for a sponsorship is
making a huge arbitrage on your brand
and your value given the amount of
impressions that these guys were getting
which when they don't make videos were
getting 100 million views a month when
they don't post anything new. That kind
of thing is a company that's 100 million
plus in revenue. So they have the
marketing department, but what they
don't have is a sales department. They
don't have a product department. They
don't have customer success. They have
none of these other departments. There's
zero out of 100 on all these. And so the
constraint isn't going 97 to 99. It's
going from 0 to 20 on these ones. What
are the choices I have here? Version one
is if I've got an advertiser who
consistently comes to me, I may be able
to negotiate some sort of equity.
Getting even 10% of a company that's
worth $100 million and then you put all
of your effort behind it and make it a
$200 or $300 million company. That's a
significantly better outcome for many of
them than what they're currently getting
paid just video to paycheck, right? The
second option is to say, "Okay, is there
a category of products that continue to
pay me the most out of all the
advertisers? Just do what Amazon does.
See what's already selling and then
clone it and make it your own and put
your name on it and make your version
yours and better. And if you do that,
then you own the entirety of that thing.
But in order to do that, you probably,
if it were me, I would go snipe some of
the top execs at some of those companies
and say, "Hey, you're currently an
executive here. Would you like to own a
slice of my thing? I'm happy to own 70%
and get three of the best guys over,
have them build their boxes behind my
thing." That's the fastest and easiest
way. The longer maybe bigger money way
is if you do it all yourself. But that's
always the trade that you have to make
as an entrepreneur is how many new
skills do I have to have in order to
pursue this new opportunity versus the
ones I currently have. The third
opportunity for them is probably the
least operational risk for them.
Accepting the fact that they just like
doing media and that's what they jam on
and they don't want to touch either of
these other business components
themselves as a creative shop that knows
how to make viral videos that they can
transform into ads. And that's where you
go from being a really good creator to
being a Madison Avenue agency that makes
ads that crush. Most influencers are
getting paid based on the impressions
that they are getting the brand for free
based on their audience. But where the
real money is made is where you take
that Tik Tok video, that YouTube short,
that Instagram video, whatever it is,
and then they put a million dollars of
ad spend behind it when it's already
shown as a winner. And then it goes from
being shown to five million people in
your audience to a 100red million people
that it converts from cold. Adspend has
no limit on reach as long as it's
profitable. So they can always expand
beyond your existing audience which
means that you get to capture all of the
upside based on how skilled you are as
an advertiser. So those would be the
three paths for that particular type of
business. It's not like okay well I'm
not one of these three businesses now
what I should do. But it's actually the
framework that we approach the problem
with which is one what problem are we
trying to solve? In each of these
businesses they wanted to make more
money. The next one is over what time
horizon. If you want to make more money
tomorrow the number of things you can do
is very limited. If you want to make
more money in 10 years you take a very
different play. If the amount of time it
might take to build a 100tory building's
foundation might take the same time it
takes to build the entirety of a 10-f
flooror building above the surface.
Somebody else building a 10f floor
building might happen way faster than
you could. Whereas yours is just
continuing to build this base before you
start building up. The next question,
which problem would we prefer solving?
Or which problem do we feel like we're
more equipped to solve? Or which
problem's easier? Because if you start
framing it in terms of the problem that
you're going to have to solve to be
successful, it actually makes it much
more controllable for you. I would say,
well, which of these do we feel more
equipped to do? Now, at acquisition.com,
we are really good at recruiting, which
is how we scale all the companies we
have is recruit talent who've already
been there, done that. And so we'd
probably say, "Hey, we feel really
confident that we could recruit somebody
in and put seed capital in to get it
going. Then we'd own the whole pie." And
so for us, that would be a problem that
we feel very confident in solving and
gives us the most upside. You have to
answer that for you given your skill
set, your resources, and your
experience.